jahr 2018 das erste komplette jahr mit
afd im bundestag liegt jetzt hinter uns
und auch in sachen afd gibt es ja
aktuell eine art weihnachtswunder eine
prominente afd frau wurde aus ihrer
fraktion geworfen wegen und jetzt kommt
die pointe zu rechter gesinnung
das ist mein humor freunde zu rechts für
die afg sachen gibts getroffen hat es
die bisherige landesvorsitzende aus
schleswig-holstein doris von
sayn-wittgenstein ja tatsächlich wegen
zu enger kontakte zu rechtsextremen
vereinigung und wohl wegen zuviel
versehentlicher ehrlichkeit im landtag
ich komme aus einer familie die fw die
ganze auf der ganzen welt verteilt es
ich habe auf der ganzen welt verwandte
undicht legen wir näher als rassismus ja
entschuldigung vernünftig lügen muss man
den afc schon können meine damen und
herren
ansonsten kann ich die fans im land aber
beruhigen es kam zu praktisch keinen
weiteren prominenten rausschmiss die afg
jugend wird vielleicht entnazifiziert
was in dem fall heißen würde komplett
aufgelöst aber unser alter kumpel bernd
hocke meine damen und herren
ja das ist die tolle nachricht des
jahres bleibt natürlich in allen ämtern
zu recht zurecht der thüringer
charmebolzen steht wie kein anderer für
den richtigen style gefällt euch der
hütte mit anzug und krawatte besser oder
gefällt euch der leseecke besser jetzt
mal bitte klatschen für den höcke mit
anzug und krawatte und jetzt mal
klatschen für den bären hückel so und
jetzt mal klatschen für den hacker der
für immer zu hause bleibt und von dem
man nie wieder etwas höher
der heute zu hause hat gewonnen ich
glaube an basisdemokratie meine damen
und herren unter diese sendung ja schon
wissen sie öfter mal beef mit der afg
hatte können wir denen zum jahresende
auch als eine art gesten der versöhnung
endlich eine eigene rubrik herzlich
willkommen zu
die fdp schickt uns endlich weiße
weihnachten mit matthias matschke
matthias matschke ist weihnachts
politischer sprecher der afd berlin herr
matschie ihre partei ist jetzt kein witz
verspricht den deutschen ernsthaft weiße
weihnachten
na ja sicherlich denn weihnachten ist
nicht bunt oder abbauen sondern weiß
auch wenn das unsere kanzlerin fátima
merkel nicht gefällt aber wenn es nach
der jede liebe kinder allein jetzt bald
statt bescherung nur noch beschneidung
ja ja ja deswegen jetzt eine wunderbare
afd aktion hashtag ja zu weißen männern
ich zitiere da den twitter account der
afg berlin weißer männer sind in den
letzten jahren für manche zu einem
schimpfwort geworden nicht für uns wir
haben jetzt extra ein afg
adventskalender online gestellt und
hinter jeder tür wartet eben nicht
braune bin ich schokolade sondern ein
hochwertiger weißer mann mein name ist
carsten und belohne ich bin bezirks
politischer sprecher der fdp fraktion
und ich denke zu weihnachten ein fest
was mir besonders wichtig ist sehr gerne
an thilo sarrazin
wer nicht
weihnachten und thilo sarrazin gehört
einfach zusammen
tschuldigung ich muss mal ganz kurz
etwas klar stellen für unsere zuschauer
zu hause was wir gerade gesehen haben
ist ausdrücklich ist ganz wichtig keine
satire
das sieht aus wie satire aber die machen
das tod erhalten ja ja ja sicherlich
mein wird ernst hier für schneider
harpprecht großer afg dichter oder und
satirischen 2 helmut schmidt kanzler und
kämpfer gegen den linken terror was die
dreht sich doch im grab um brecht den
übrigens falsch geschrieben habt war
kommunist und schmidt in der spd
ja klar beides nicht schön aber sie
waren weiß wir wollen weiße weihnachten
geben
ein anderes beispiel ein parteikollege
horst hülsmann sprecher des afg
landkreises leipzig der sitzt neulich
vor der glotze an nichts böses es läuft
werbung für rüben weil davos die
üblichen bilder alle futtern
überfahrenen tiere lecker lecker und
denn
sitzt seelenruhig und afrikaner und
heute unsere gute teams trennen und
damit ein afrikaner ist terrorist als
erstes normalste von der welt darauf
schreibt würde man natürlich einen
wütenden brief eine firma rügen bayern
ja sei entsetzt über das harmonische
integrieren von bürgern aus afrika in
fröhlicher genießer und zwar kann sich
afg spanier feiern
also es in der partei klar aber nicht
mehr sprecher und damals ihr der weiße
mann wird diskriminiert
deswegen meine neue protestaktion
hashtag weiße essen afrikanern die t
hooft weg
jeden tag ein kilo damit dies nicht mehr
kriegen
ich weckte hofft auf bildung dürften
absolut matthias mann schlimmer kommen
naja
ein jahr auf dem bundestag man spricht
auch von der analen phase der politik
[Gelächter]
und was ist so was gab's doch dafür
viele wunderbare momente an die man sich
nie wieder erinnern möchte zb wollte die
afg von der groko die zitat zahl der
behinderten in deutschland wissen und
zwar insbesondere die durch heirat
innerhalb der familie entstanden und wie
viele dieser fälle einen
migrationshintergrund hätten
hahahaha im deutschen bundestag wird
wieder gekürzt
ja und das hat nichts mit der kantine zu
tun ein highlight und symptomatisch für
das neue klima der legendäre trotzkopf
auftritt von alice weide
[Musik]
wir freuen uns jetzt schon auf ihre
autobiografie alois seidl main stammt
und dann ja dann ja aber billig
tschuldigung aber ja und dann hat die
liebe alice ihren laden in sachen
parteispenden endlich auf profi niveau
gebracht danke dafür wobei man muss
sagen die etablierten parteien sind in
sachen geld besorgen ja auch sehr gut
philip morris sponsert den cdu-parteitag
und aus werbung für zigaretten bleibt
einfach erlaubt
ein schelm wer hier einst den song wild
die afg hat geld aus der schweiz gericht
was ich nicht kapiere das ist ja quasi
geld mit migrationshintergrund aber gut
ihre entscheidung ihre entscheidung
immerhin die haben so bezahlt ja und
sich quasi nackig gemacht vor den
behörden dafür gibt es von uns noch den
vollpfosten in der gauland edition mit
diebstahlsicher karierten badehose und
natürlich stil echt mit vogelschießen
herzlichen glückwunsch wie bei alice und
das hier das ist dein lied
[Musik]
die spendengelder kommen
spendengelder kommen
da kommen die gelder kommen stellen
ständen
geld für alice weiter
[Musik]
wenn man gern die klappe aufreißt
und die altparteien ist
[Musik]
aber von illegalen gelten anwalt zahlt
von likes bei facebook kauft und auf
liegt ist das nicht alles weil die
folgen kann
obwohl das passt perfekt
zu alt
wenn du das
der schweiz sollen so nötig erst dann
jedoch schwarz putzen weil du so als
ideen
geld für alice war
[Musik]
[Applaus]